والى حمله الاقالات والاستقالات الواسعه
في اوكرانيا المعلن اخيرا جاءتك اولي
واكبر فضيحه بهذا الحجم منذ بدا الحرب في
اوكرانيا وذلك بعد اعلان الحكومه
الاوكرانيه لقالته نحو 12 مسؤلا والاقاله
نحو 12 مسؤولا على خلفيه قضيه فساد تتعلق
بعمليات شراء امدادات للجيش باسعار مبالغ
فيها رئيس الاوكرانيسكي يعتبر ان هذه
الاقالات هي عمليه تطهير ضروريه متعهدا
باتخان اجراءات اضافيه مؤكدا ان عمليه امر
منصف وضروريه للدفاع عن اوكرانيا فضلا عن
انها تدعم التقارب مع المؤسسات الاوروبيه
اما الولايات المتحده فقد رحبت بدورها
بالاقالات معلنه انه لم يتم اي اموال
امريكيه قدمت لمساعده اوكرانيا
كم اعتبر متحدث باسم الخارجي الامريكيه
نيترو برايس ان الشعب الاوكرانيه كان
واضحا جدا بشان رغبته في الحكم النزيه
والشفافيه من جهه ثانيه قال نائب وزير
الدفاع الاقراني في الجيش
وهو احد الذين استقال على خلفيه هذه
القضيه قال ان الفضيحه هجوم اعلامي مصطنع
يستند الى حجج واحد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]